心あったりいい心あったりはします
いわゆる善の心も生まれたり
悪い心も生まれたりする
でまあ それまあ世の中でいろいろまあ何が罪ですか
何が善ですかということは
まあみんな哲学的に考えたりはして
まあそれをはっきりした結論はないんですけど
仏教ではきちんと定義しておいてますし
仏教の定義っていうのはあくまでも心理学的な定義で
こういうこういう心は不善であって
こういうこういう心は善であるというふうに決まってるし
ただ単に神に逆らったんだから罪とかね
決まりを破ったんだから罪とかね
そういうふうな この社会的な立場から
人間のいろいろ理想から概念から作った立場から善悪判断はしません
善悪判断というのは あくまでも自分の心の状態から判断するんであって
心の状態によって心は善になるか不正になるかということを決めます
で それを説明は前ずっとしてきましたから
この十九種類の強情信称を勉強すると
我々に理解できることは
その強情信称だから どんな良い心にも必ずも生まれる心臓なんですね
ということは 心は善良い心であると
罪の心ではないんだと
悪の心ではないんだと
これは清らかな心だよと決める時は
基本的にこの十九種類の心祖が必ずも必要ということ
そこでこの十九種類を勉強すると
私たちにはいくらかのいい心って良い心はどういうものかということが理解できます
で そのためにこの十九は別々に勉強した方がいいということをこの前も言いました
そこでまあ一番先に出てくるのはサッダーという言葉であって
サッダーっていうのは宗教的な信仰というよりは
すごくこのしっかりしている性格
まあ自分がやる事についてまあ自信があること
自分の生き方 自分のやることについて
まあいくらかまあこれでいいという自信があること
あるいは確信なんですね
で ある程度でいえば 心のあるある何か強さみたいなものなんですね
一般的な言葉でいえば
心はしっかりしているんだと
いわゆる何か中途半端な状態がなくて
まあどうしようかどうしようかって悩むほどでもなくて
じゃあこうしましょうというふうな
このしっかりした状態なんですね
で 厳密に定義すると 心はすごく明るいということで
仏教長老がこの汚れている水が濁っていると
何か昔いろいろ薬を入れるんですね
何か植物 何か入れたら
その水の汚れが植物にどんどんどんどん吸収されて
水がすごいきれいな水になって飲めるような状態になると
そういう風にこの濁っている心に信という心祖が入ったら
この濁りがどんどんどんどんなくなって
すごく清らかな使い物になる心になるんだと
ですから 信というものはそういうふうなもので
単なるこのある宗教の概念で
信仰すること 仏法僧を信じること
神様を信じること 仏様を信じることは信仰だよと言ったら
そんなものは迷信であって
単なる それほど意味があるわけじゃないんですね
そういうただ訳の分からない何かを信じ込んで
それに束縛されて執着されて生活する場合は
心は暗いんですね 自分の生き方はいつでもその自分を信仰している対象から決めていただいてますからね
宗教的な何か信じてしまえば
自分で判断するっていうことはなくなっちゃうんですね
コーラン信じておけば
聖書を信じておけば いつでもコーランやら聖書やら読んで読んでどうすればいいか
どうすればいいかというふうにやらなくちゃいけない
それは自分が誤解したならば
自分の解釈が間違っていたならば
非常に生き方は間違っちゃうし
それは宗教でよく見えることで
コーランを誤解して大変
まあ戦争ばっかりやるし
キリスト教聖書はもうとことん自分勝手に誤解して
世の中はむちゃくちゃもう戦争の世界に作ってしまったし
別に聖書でもコーランでも戦え戦え
相手を殺せっていうことは全然書いてないし
ですから まあでもまあ信仰に基づいて
そういうふうな まあ厳密に神の言葉だと思って
まあ思って思うのはいいんだけど
なんで神の言葉だったら自分勝手に判断するんですか？っていうことも聞きたくはなるんだけど
で それでまあ自分の欲望で判断するんだから
わがままで それで間違ったりはするし
そういうことで 人間の生き方は自由になるんじゃなくて
もう行く道がすごく幅が狭くなるんですね
ですから そういうふうな信仰っていうのは
現場向こうでバッティという信愛ですか
何とかという言葉に訳してますけど
で  [背景音楽]で そういうことではなくて
まあなんかこの暗い心
やる気がない心 そこを明るくなって元気に戻るというふうな働きなんですね
心というのは ですから
あくまでも良い心っていうのは明るい心であるということを
我々はそこで理解できるだろうと思います
そこでサッダ次に出てくるサティというものは
まあ私たち仏教では大変基本的な実践
始まるところ使っているサティであって
まあ気づくことというのは
物事をいくらかよく気づく
気づいて把握しているということなんですね
その時でもしっかりするんですよ
我々の心は きちんと私たちの前に
今現在という瞬間で起こる現象について
自分が自分の知ってるんだと気づいてるんだと
いわゆる今の瞬間しっかりと生きてるということなんですよ
で 今何が起こるかとわからない
でも 過去のことに悩んだり
将来のことに心配したりとか
あるいは怒りに陥ったり
欲望に陥ったりすると
今起こるということは人間には気づかないんですね
ですから その時は心が硬くなっちゃうんですね
過去のことにふけっていると
人は動かないんです 行動は失っちゃう
将来のことを心配すると
また人の行動はそこで止まってしまう
で 暗くなってしまう そういうことじゃなくて
現実に自分の周りにあるものにちゃんと気づいて
何が起こるかと 今何が起こっているか
今自分が何をしているんですかということは
いくらか気づいているところはもうサティであって
それもすごい行動的な心の働きなんですね
自分の周りの自分の体と関係ある周りのことをちゃんと知ってるっていうことは
その人はもうある程度で自由な行動できる
で また明るいっていうことは
またそれでまた成立してしまうんですね
行動的になると で そういうふうな説明言って全部説明する必要今日はないんだけど
それでヒリオッタパ抜きます
ヒリオッタパっていうのもまた
ただ元気で明るく行動するだけではなくて
あるところで自分をコントロールしなくちゃいけない
元気だからといって 明るいんだからといって
確信が自信があるんだからといって
何でもバカにするんではないんですよ
そこで智慧のある人は
自分の行動はいくら自信があってもいくらかコントロールするんですね
自信があるんだからって何でもやるんじゃなくて
やっぱりヒリとオッタパですか
慚と愧が働いてくる こんなことはやらない方がいいと
やろうとするならばできるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれやるのは良くないんだと
そういうことやっちゃったら
ちょっと自分の幸福は危険になりますから
怖いんだと そういうことやったら恥ずかしくて幸福になるわけじゃないというふうなことで
この一つの二つの その心の働きをもって
いくらか自分の行動を自分でコントロールする
自分で判断して だから慚愧というのは
二つは自分が自分の心から生まれるものであって
誰かに言われてるんだから
何々さんがこういうことをするなと言ったんだから私はしませんよと言っても
自分の気持ちとしてはそういうことをしたいかしたくないかっていうのはまた別な話なんですね
ですから 言われたんだからやりませんという時の心の働きと
私はこんなことやったらもうやばいんだから
もうよくない 恥ずかしい
だからしませんという場合は
もうかなり自分が自由なんです
自分で自由であって その上自分が何でも無茶苦茶やろうとはしない
いくらか落ち着いてきてコントロールできる
自分の幸福になる行動しかしない
他人の幸福になる行動しかしない
ただやりたいんだからといって自分犠牲になることやら
他人を犠牲害与えることやら
もうやめてやめる そういう気持ちが生まれてくると
それは立派な良い心なんですね
それ次に出てくるのはアローバとアモーハなんですね
アローバ・アドーサ ローバっていうのは何かにくっつくこと
定着すること 何かにぼけるというか
そういう状態なんですね
我々は何かに定着してしまったら
もう真理また見えなくなっちゃう
執着するから 行動は確実にそこで止まってもらう
止まる 心が硬くなってしまう
無執着のところっていうのは
そういう硬くなる心ではなくて
すごく柔軟性があって
行動的な心なんですね
そういうのは大体分かりやすいことで
例えば具体的に私たちが何かやりたいものがあって
それは確実になんとかやりますと徹底的に決めてしまったならば
それで自分の他の行動は全部もう止まらなくちゃいけないんですね
それ決まったことにしか頭が働かないんですね
自分だけの世界が生まれてくるんですよ
殻が生まれてくるんですね
むさぼりから 例えば ある人について自分の執着が生まれたんだと
そうすると 自分の頭の中でその人を入れて
そこでもう殻ができて
それ以上はもう自分には自由な行動をすることができなくなっちゃう
だからそういうことだから
欲が生まれると心の柔軟性また失って硬くなる
で 怒りが生まれたらまた同じことで
まあ物事に対する拒絶反応だから
拒絶反応生まれたらまたこの心が行動を失ってしまった
このうつ病なんかになっている人々は
ほとんどの怒り 怒りなんですね
そこで心は怒りで行動すると
社会のことやら自分のことやら拒絶するんです
否定するんですね 否定すると同時に
それで怠けが出てきたり
行動はしたくなくなったりとかでなってきて
それ結果として我々はこの人はうつ病にかかっているんだという心の中で怒りというものは働いているんですね
怒りっていうのは 対象について自分が反対する
逆らう 拒絶する 拒否する
なぜ拒否するかというと
対象を受け入れたらこちらで行動しなくちゃいけない
そこで怠けというものがあるんですね
ですから 拒否した方が行動しなくて済みますよというふうなことになってしまう
それで拒否することをやってますけど
怒りを 結局自分がまたうつ病になって
精神的な病気になって
何もできなくなった状態で
心はもう硬くなってしまったら
また文句を言うんですね
こういう状態は苦しみだから
何とかしてちょうだいと
何もできませんよ そういう精神的に病気になる人々は
騙して一時的にちょっと子供を騙すように
もうそういうカウンセラーやら精神科やら
それは一時的に人を騙すということをやりますが
それは治すことはできないんです
治すことできないのは
心の底からやっぱり怒りやら貪瞋痴やら生まれないように
その代わりにアローバ・アドーサやら
アローバっていうのはみんなと仲良く生活することであって
アモーハ・アドーサというのは怒りの反対の言葉で
慈しみの感情で みんな同じ生命だと
みんな平等だと みんなのために行動しなくちゃいけないと
みんなのおかげで生きているんだから
私もみんなにそれ分の恩返しをして生きじゃなくちゃいけないというふうな
この行動的な思考なんですね
そこを生まれない限りは
そういうのはうつ病とか何とかとか
治りくはないんですね
薬で抑えることもできますけど
薬飲んじゃったらいきなりホルモンが出てきて
一時的に体は行動する
神経刺激されて それで薬は終わって
その機能終わってしまったら
またもっとさらに落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
どうせ薬にはもう何て言いますか
副作用というものがありますから
そうするとまた飲まなくちゃいけないし
それで性格治りますか
全然治らないんですね
薬に依存するだけで 自分を治せないで何かに依存して引っかかって
もうなんかごまかしをしようと
だから薬を飲んで明るく振る舞う人々は
ものすごく人を自分を騙してるんですね
私は大丈夫だ 薬飲んだんだから
大丈夫わけじゃないんですよ
薬に頼ってるだけで そういうことで
この怒りというものが生まれてきたら
心はすぐそこで行動しなくしない状態になって凍ってしまって
もう硬くなる ですから
善神というのはやっぱり怒りの反対の慈しみの心
空気のような心でどこにでも入りやすい穴があったらすぐそこに入ってしまう
もう何のことなく 穴の形について文句は言わない
そういう形の穴だったら
私は空気は入りませんよとか言わないで
どこにでも入るんです
硬いものだったらそういうことはできないんですね
硬いものだったら入れる穴の形も決めてもらわなきゃ入れないんです
ですから この柔軟性というか
心 そういうふうに明るくなってもらうんですね
なるんです とにかく で
次に中射という言葉あって
私は今日言いたかったのは次のリストなんですね
カーエムルタチッタムルタカーエカンマンニヤタチッタカンマンニヤタカーヤパーグンニヤタチッパパーグンニヤタカーユッジュカタチットッジュカタというところな
んですね
そこでさらに今まで説明したものはシン
ネン サッダサティ それからヒリオッタッペ
ザンキ アロ アローバ アドーセ
そういうのは まあ善であることはよくわかりますね
大体一般的には それだけで十分なのに
そこでパットラマッジャッタタとかね
落ち着けて 物事について混乱しないでああだこうだではなくて
何をしようともすごく何か落ち着いた状態で行動するということなんです
パットラマッジャッタタというのは
中射ですかね 日本語の
それからカーヤパッササディ
チッタパッササディっていうのは明確に落ち着いている状態なんですよ
日本語でそこをそれほど私はあまり言葉あるかどうか分かりませんだけど
パッササディっていうのは
なんかすごく落ち着いてる状態で
例えば窓を開けたらものすごいうるさい音が入るでしょ
それで落ち着きがなくなっちゃうんですね
さっと窓を閉めちゃったら
すーっと落ち着いていくんですね
我々の心っていうのは
静かになったんだから
そういうふうな感じで
この落ち着いてない混乱状態でいら立っている心がすーっと落ち着いてくる
ですから 善神がある場合は落ち着いているということは確実なんです
で それからこのカーヤラフタ
ラフタっていうのはまた同じ意味なんですよ
軽いっていうことで パッササディ落ち着くということで
ラフっていうのは軽いという意味なんですよ
[笑い]だから心はものすごく硬くなって重くなって
もう重くなってくると行動はないし
どんどん軽くなって軽くなってくると行動するということになるんですね
次のことはムドゥ ムドゥっていうことは
英語のソフトというソフト
軽い それからソフトで柔らかい状態という
あまり言葉はこれ心の問題だから
心はソフトで柔らかいっていうのは
このちょっとしたことで泣いたり喚いたりする状態ではないんですよ
私たちは一般的にはすごいソフトな心といえば
ちょっとしたことですぐ気になったりとか
もう泣いたりとかする
それはソフトじゃなくて弱いということなんですよ
ソフトな心っていうのは
もうまた違うんですよ
もっと力強くて 人に当たらない
だから何よという風に当たらなくて
まあ物事を理解して ああそうですか
まあそうというふうに
なんとなくこのソフトな状態で
それムドゥターということで
次にカンマンジェター
で ソフトだけではなくてカンマンジェター
カンマンジェターっていうのは
まあ適用ですか もうどんな
まあ一応行動に適応している状態
適している状態 カンマンジェターというのは
いわゆるファンクショナブル
ワークアブルという ファンクションというのは行動するって
ワークというのは行動する
ワーク ワーキングコンディションということなんですよ
あるいはfunctionable workableあるいは違う英語の単語で言うのであればアクティブ
という状態なんですね
いわゆる活発状態っていうことで
で パーグンジェターという言葉っていうのは
まああのカンマンジェターとほんのわずかなわずかな差なんですね
で 日常生活の言葉からそれを理解しなくちゃいけないんだけど
このできる状態 いわゆるこのアクティブ状態っていうのは
もうやりたがってる状態ですけど
できるかできないかってのはまた別なんですね
ですから やりたい気持ち出てくると
人は何でもどうしても明るいんですよ
それはやりやりたいんですよと
やりましょうってするかもしれませんだけど
できるかないかっていうことは
またちょっと別な話なんですね
ですから このできる状態の心にあると
ですから カンマンジェターっていうのは
もうアクティブ状態でできる状態
パーグンジェター パーグンジェター何でしたっけ
ん？あ 連達性 次にカーユジュカタ
チットジュカタということ
で 柔軟性あるんだからといって
この どうにもなる状態ではなくて
まあ行動的な心で行動はちゃんと果たせるぐらいはもう強くなければいけない
だからこの直 単直線 ちゃんともう決まったものをできるような状態
大体そこでこの先の部分で
このサッダサティヒリオッタッタというところを説明したところで
一応宗教からでも 一般人間の考え方から理解できるんですね
セニカークタっていうのは
で これがサッダサティヒリオッタッタアローラアローラアドーサ
このサタ 信と念とザンと気と布団とプチという
で そこはなるほど これは善心だと
悪の心じゃないかということは
普通の人間の常識でわかるかもしれません
わかりますからね 大体
でも仏教でさらにその上何かメッセージが入ってるんですよ
もう単なるこの宗教的な説明ではなく
で あの そういう宗教的な定義で善悪
善の心決めるというよりは
もっと普遍的な心理学的なとこだよということは言いたいんだから
これは私の意見なんですけど
次のところ入ってると思いますよ
タットレ・マッジャッパタ
注釈 カーヤ・パッサディ・チッタ・パッサディ
ケーヤンでしょ で カーヤ・ラフタ・チッタ・ラフタ・カーヤ・ムドタ・チッタ・ムドタ・カーヤ・カンマンニャタ・チッタ・カンマンニャタ・カーヤ・パグンニャ
タ・チッタ・パグンニャタ・カーヤ・ジュカタ・チッタ・ジュカタというセット
明確にそれ心が明るい
柔軟性がある 行動的である
アクティブであるということは
もう繰り返し繰り返し言うことなんです
もっとパーリ語の単語があったならば
もしかするとその心象はもっとリストが伸びる可能性ありましたんだけど
心はアクティブである
明るいですよという 我々一般的にこの明るいというのものすごい大雑把な言葉ですけど
それは現代人の愛という言葉と同じなんですよ
どんな宗教を覚る人も
愛という言葉 ラブという言葉
偉そうに大胆な大変な高度な言葉だと思って
もう必死にそれをそれに死のうと思ってる
思ってるぐらいでも必死になって説明しますけど
無茶無茶ですけど まあ曖昧な言葉で
まあ大雑把な言葉で 我々の理解も曖昧なんですね
でも一般の日常生活の中で
我々は厳密に言葉使わない
だいたい大雑把な意味で言葉使うっていうのが普通ですよ
厳密に言葉使うってことはしない
ですから 我々は日常の世界で
あの人は明るいやとかという時の心の状態ですね
そこで厳密にきめ細かく分けて説明しているのは
明るいって言ったっても
もうひどいことをする人がいるんですよ
あまりに明るくて ですから
そこで  斬と規を入れてちゃんと行動をコントロールする
明るいだけではなくて
あまり良くないことはしない
あまりではなくて 良くない
いけないことは人に 人を傷つくことはしない
自分を傷つけることはしない
そこで気をつける そういう風な
この明るさと それ故 あの
こういうこういう性格も入っているよ
だから大雑把な説明ではもうチェットする説明にならないんだから
そういうふうな説明が入っていて
ですから 私はとにかく言いたいのは
我々の心はいつでも いつでもと言ったってどうかな
我々は心がもし行動的で
明るくて 元気で ある時は
その時は先進なんですよ
で 暗くて なんかやる気がなくなって
まあ言われるんだからやる
まあしょうがないだから行動する
やらねばならないんだから何かする
やらなきゃ大変だからとかね
こういうことをしなきゃ
しなきゃつまらないんだとか
退屈だからとか なんとかする行動っていうのは専心にはならないんですよ
あれは強引に自分が落ち込むんだから
強引になんとかして上に上に持って
強引に上に引っ張ってるだけなんですね
ですから やらねばならないんだから
仕事をする人はすごいストレス溜まっちゃう
ああ 嫌だっていう状態になってもう怠けに陥っちゃうんですね
これをやらなきゃ叱られるんだとか
危険だとか大変だとか
そういうふうにこの何とかこの衝動っていうのは強引に作ってもらって行動する
その活発的な心の状態っていうのは
まあまあ本物じゃないんですね
そうじゃなくて もうなんとなく明るくて元気で
もうさっさっさと行動すると
それ行動するために言い訳別にないんです
一生懸命自分に何かいろんなことを言い返して言い返してあげて
自分に暗示かけてかけて
ああ こういうことをしなくちゃとかね
そういうふうにいいことをすると
あまり本物じゃない まあ分かりやすく例えるならば
例えば寄付をしなくちゃいけないんだという状態になっちゃったら
もう心の中では困ったな
もうお金をあげなくちゃいけないし
みんなあげてるんだからどうしようかとかね
そういう考えじゃ みんなあげてるんだからこれ恥ずかしいとかね
あげなきゃ自分の立場がなくなっちゃうんだとかね
そういう風にいろいろ考えて考えた末で
それは見えない人には見えない
本人にも気がつかない
なぜならば この考えることは瞬時に考えるんだから
そういうふうな この自分にいろんな暗示をかけた上で行動すると
確実にストレスが溜まる
ですから そういういろんな条件を考えた考えた末で
寄付でも何でもする人も後で文句を言うんですよ
必ず いわゆる喜びを感じてないんです
ああ よかったと 専心の行動っていうのはストレスはたまらない
後で思い出しても ああいうことをできましたとか自慢できるんですね
そこで私は分かりやすくするために使う言葉は
自分の心を自分を褒めてくれる
自分の心があなたもよくやるもんだよとというふうに
自分の心 自分の良心ですか
自分のコンセンスというものが自分を褒めてくれる行動っていうのは
思い出せば出すほど元気なんですよ
この間私はこういうことをしましたよと
もう突然 また十年経ったところで思い出したっても
すごく気持ちいいということは
自分の心 自分を褒めてるんですね
それは自慢とはちょっと違うんです
自慢するのは もう他人に自慢するんですよ
それは自分のために立場がないんだと
自分は貶されているんだという
このコンプレックスから自慢したくなる
それは不善なんですね
その時は嘘を言うんです
これは自慢ではなくて
自分の心 自分を褒めてくれることだから
別に人と人に言いふらさなきゃ気が済まないということはないんですね
一人で思い出す時でも
すごい気持ちいい それまた人にも言いたくなるかもしれません
だけど それ自慢ということよりは
あんた知ってますか？こういうことできますよという
なんかもう言いたくてしょうがないという状態だけなんですね
だから私は偉いぞという結論ではなくて
もうただ言いたくてしょうがないという
ですからこの自分の心が自分を褒めてくれる状態
そういう行動はセンターの行動であって
その時の心は専心だからストレスは溜まってない
ですから 後で思い出すっても気持ちいいだけであって
気持ち悪いわけじゃない
そういうことは仏教は心理学的に説明するところはないんだから
説法だから 仏教の説法の世界でこう言うんですよ
いいことをしたならば
それはいつでも思い出しなさいと
いいことをしましたということは
ですから 習慣として人々はノートでも書いておくんですよ
昔で自分が何かいいことをしたならば
それをちゃんとメモを書いておく
自分の日記として だから自分の日記っていうのは
まあそういうくだらないことではなくて
何か善行 善行をしたならばそれを書いておく
日記でしたから 昔は そうすると自分の日記っていうのは
読めば読むほどもう楽しくてしょうがないというものになっちゃうんですよ
自分の記録ではないんです
自分の過去を何とかして記録しておく
それは自我があることであって
自慢したくなっちゃうことであって
あんまり明るい行動ではないんです
私という人がここにいましたよということは
みんなに言いたがる がでかくてとか
そういうことではなくて
このいいことを思い出してください
いいことをしたならば
それをちゃんと書いておいてでも忘れないようにしてくださいと
で 思い出すたびにどうなるかというと
説法するときは そのまた徳が済みますよと
思い出せば思い出すほど
自分が過去で行った徳がどんどん倍になって倍になって
もう倍増というんですか
もう増やして増やしていきますよということなんです
そうすると 信仰深い人々は
まあそういう信仰の立場からそれ取るんですね
いいことをしたら それを一生懸命思って思って念じて
もうさらに自分の徳をどんどん増やしてもらわなくちゃいけないんだという風にも簡単に取っています
それを現代的に解釈しちゃうと
私は現代的な言葉で解釈すると
今までやった解釈であって
いいことをしたという善心が生まれたということは
自分の心の良心が自分を褒めてくれる
あんたもなかなかいいことをやるんではないかということは
自分の心褒めてくれるんだから
それは正直な気持ち それでまた思い出すというのは
またすごい気持ちいい
それを気持ちいい 明るくなるということだから
思い出すたびに明るい心が生まれる
善心が生まれる ですから
長時間そういう人々には明るい行動的な心で生きることはできるんです
だから 伝統的に言えば
徳がどんどん増えますよということも同じことなんです
徳っていうのは幸福の同義語だよとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
道徳じゃなくて功徳 徳というものは幸福の同義語ですよと
だから幸福っていうことは
やっぱり元気で明るくいられるということでもあるんですね
心が明るくて活発的であるならば
別にどうったことはない
問題何もないんですから
そういう人々にとって
そういうことだから 善と不善判断する場合は
不善の定義は全部終わりましたからね
善の定義の場合は 自分の心が自分を褒めてくれる状態
行動的な状態 明るい状態
活発な状態は善心だと理解しておいてください
だからこの世の中で 人間の中で
人間というのは明るいんだったら結構まあいいもんでしょうに
明るい人とは誰でも付き合いたいし
暗い人とあまり付き合いたくない
明るい人はどんどん増えても
いくら増えたっても何の負担は誰にもないんですね
もうどうせどうせ明るいんだから
どんな問題が起ころうが
どんなトラブルがあろうとも
明るい人々はすぐそういうものはもう解決する
そういう人々にとってはいろんな乗り越えがたいチャレンジがあればあるほど
もうチャレンジをして
そういうものを乗り越えていく
ですから 世の中で明るい人々は
行動的な人々は増えれば増えるほどよろしいということで
だからそういう心が仏教で善心というんです
そういう心の状態  [背景音楽]今は私たちはこの新興宗教的な対策で
この徳を積もう徳を積もうとやっているのは本当にあの
どうかと判断できますよ
人が何か徳を積もうと思って自分を犠牲にして何かするかもしれません
で それによってその人に自信ついてくるか
その人は明るくなっているか
すごい元気になっているかということから見ると
そうであるならば もうその行動が善行動だとわかるんですよ
寄付はするは 奉仕はするは
それでも家は無茶苦茶になるならば
家庭の問題は 子供の面倒を見てあげないんだから
お母さんが一生懸命徳を積もうと思っていろんな奉仕活動をやったりして
それで子供たちが不良になったとかね
そういう風になってくると
あれは本当に善心症かどうかもう疑問なんですね
ですから 行動で判断できません
善悪判断 心の状態で善悪判断はするんです
人にいくらかの額の寄付したんだから
もう不善行為だよとは決められません
そのお金あげた心はどんなものかと見て
それで判断しなくちゃいけない
例えば社会に奉仕する人が
家の状態はもう大変不幸な状態になって
家の人々を犠牲にして社会奉仕ばっかりやってるならば
その人はどこかから逃げているということは見えるんじゃないんですかね
家のことやら旦那さんのことやら
子供のことから逃げているのではないか
その人に子供たちが不良になっても言い訳があるんですね
私は社会のために一生懸命頑張っていたんだから
本当に残念ですと 子供たちを育てることはできなかったと
というふうなことで言い訳
それ逃げるんですね ですから
現実から逃げるためにやっていることは
もう善心になれるかならないかということは
まあちょっと問題で その人の心の状態見なくちゃいけない
奉仕する人は誰であろうとも奉仕はする
ですから そういう人の家庭はバラバラになる可能性はないんです
もし本当に清らかな心で奉仕すると
子供たちから見ても立派なことをしているんだから
じゃあ私たちもそれなりに何とかしなくちゃということになって
自分たちがもうよくなるんですよ
ですから この行動で物事を決めるんじゃなくて
やっぱり心の状態で物事を決めなくちゃいけない
まあ大体その十九種類の善心証が基本的で
もっと単純に言うならば
心は明るいかないかということはもう基本なんです
善心の場合は 明るくてまた活動的で柔軟性がある
その状態なんですよ ですから
そういうところで現代心理学と繋がるのはそこら辺だけ
人がいろんな精神的な悩みあったりいうと訴えたりするでしょ
仏教から見れば それは単なる怒りであって
失望感とかなんとかとか
いろんな概念いっぱいあるんですね
心理学の世界では なんとかコンプレックス
なんとかコンプレックスとか
ああだこうだとか どれまでも膨大な量の定義
精神状態に対する定義
定義あってもたった二つしかない
欲望と怒り いろんなものに欲望を作ったり作ったりする
それを追っかけて行って人はひどい目に遭うと
それは一部なんです もう一つは欲望あるんだけど
それは叶わない それで失望感の世界が
それで怒りが生まれてくる
怒りが生まれてない人はもう失望感だけでそこで陥ってしまいますけど
それでもう行動的な人はもう欲望が叶わなかったんだから
その代わりに巨大な怒りを作ったりする
そして怒りの行動をする
反社会的な行動 自分を犠牲にする行動はどんどんやってしまったりとか
例えば子供の場合は 自分の希望通りの物事いかないと
ある子供はなんとなく落ち込んで落ち込んで
家から出ないで 部屋からも出ないで
閉じ込められているかもしれません
それは失望感だけで止まったと
もう一人の子がそうじゃなくて
むちゃくちゃ暴力振るかもしれません
家庭の中で その差なんですよ
暴力振る子はもう失望感から怒りを作って
とにかくアクティブですよ
悪い方向にしてもいい方向にしても
だからそこはもう怒りにしてしまって
暴力振ったりはすると
ですから基本的には自分の希望叶ってないというぐらいのことで
それをどう解釈するかというそのことにははっきりとあなたはどんな希望を持ってるかとハッキリ知りなさいという念なんですよ
本人知らないんですね
なんであなた家庭内暴力振ってるんですかね
なんで学校を登校拒否しているんですかね
聞いても知らない ですからサティっていうのはもう欠点全然ない
そこにサティなんか入れてもらうと
この状況はセットだから全部ついてくるんです
だから暴力の問題解決するのは置いといて
登校拒否の問題は解決するのは置いといて
それに説法するんじゃなくて
まずあなたの人生観やら希望とか
あってほしいもの あなたにしてほしいものとかね
全部明確に書いてくださいということが一番大事なんですよ
学校の友達はあなたにどうすればいいか
先生たちは子供のだったらもう世界は狭いんだからね
難しくはないし 先生たちはどうすればいいかと
母親はどのようにしてくれればいいかと
父親はどのようにすればいいんですかと
自分自身の体と心について
自分がどうなればいいかということは
もうもうノートブック 2つでもいいし
3つでもいい 全部書いてくださいと
書くことによって自分に気づくんですね
そこで書いたものを 2回目読んでみると
それで終わりますよ それぐらいの問題っていうのは
暴力とかなんだこととか
別にアドバイス 指導とか全然要りません
じゃああなたが書いた希望のリストをもう一回落ち着いて読んでみなさいと
読んでみると自分を見るということはそこで行ってしまって
あまりにもくだらなくて
バカバカらしくて 自分の希望っていうのは
それでもあんなバカバカらしいんだと自分で気づくんですよ
だいたいそれぐらいの頃にそういうのは終わってしまいます
それでもし心が明るくなって行動的になったならば
正しく それからもう毎日幸福感を味わいますから
もうその道で行ってしまうんです
ですから まあ 1度でも本当の善心が生まれたら
大体人々っていうのは善行動
いい行動をしたくなるんです
すごい気持ちいいもんなんですよ
最近亡くなったなんとかさんでしたっけ
あのテレサさんにしても
で まあ大した女の人ではなかったんだけど
インドに行って まあちょっとちょっとこのいいことをする機会に出会って
そう自分がいいことをしたんだ
したところで そこがすごい気持ちいいんです
で 彼女同様に何かどうか死にかけてる女の人見つけて
彼女は一生懸命自分の何でしたっけ？息子を恨んでいたんだと
私はこういう風に道路に捨てたのは息子ですよと
道路に捨てられてもう死ぬようにしたな
息子ですよ 恨んでその女の人は死にかけてて
それでこの人はもうやることもないんだから
その辺に連れて行って面倒見てあげたところで
自分の聖書でも言ってるんだからね
死ぬ前にみんなに対して恨みは全部捨てて
みんな許してあげなくちゃいけない
これはちゃんと聖書にある教えで
許しなさいとみんなのことを人を許す人でないと自分の罪を許してもらわないんだと
それも法則はその通りですから
我々には人を許してあげる気持ちがない限りは
自分の罪から抜け出ること
抜けられることは絶対できないんですね
そこで彼女もまあ初めての仕事だから一生懸命まあその人に親切にしてあげることで
その人の心がもう良くなってきて
その母親が死ぬ前に子供を許してあげたんですね
で 自分が本当に自分の聖書を言われたところにいいことをしました
それで客観的に見ても
テレサさんがいいことをしたんですね
そこですごく味があるんですよ
後で思い出したって 今もう死ぬちょっと前にその人がそれを思い出したっても
もうものすごい気持ちいいんです
自分が年取って終わるまでやった活動はいかに始めたかと思い浮かんじゃうと恥ずかしいやという気持ち全くないでしょうね
こういうくだらないことで始めた
そんなことなくて ああいうあの母親に会わなかったら
私はこういう行動をしなかっただろうということなんですね
だからもう年取ってから思い出すたってもすごい気持ちいい
そういうのはもう正真正銘の善行為なんですね
もう問題なくはっきりと
なぜなら 思い出せば出すほど元気になって
それで彼女はいいことをした経験があって
それですごい気持ちいい充実感がある
尼さんじゃない シスターになってよかったと
聖書に出会ってよかったと
いいことをできたという幸福感がその瞬間に本人が味わったんです
そうすると その味は忘れ難いんです
それでスーッと一生かけてでもいいことをする
テレサさんがもうもう体ボロボロになって死にかけ
もう自分も病気になったり
いろんなね 何病気でしたっけ
血貧 それもそういういろいろ自分の体も病気になったり
いろいろあったのは最後は心臓とか
それは年取って亡くなったんだけど
そういういろんなことがあっても
そんなこと構わずいいことをしたんですね
ただ 自分の名前が売れてほしいとか
世界からみんなから認めてほしいとか
そんなもう全然考えてない
その代わり口がうるさいんです
褒めてもらうところじゃなくて
で 僕はそういういろんなところで
この彼女にいろいろ批判があった
一つはこのローマ法王がもう認めてくれるのはローマ法王が一番ずるいんですけど
ものすごくいいことをすると忘れない
無視できない 無視できないと教会が認めてあげる
あるいはもう初めからもう戦地全能だから全然知らない一般の人々がもう一生懸命褒めてあげると
しょうがないと悔しくて認めるという状態
ずっとそういう歴史なんです
ローマ教会っていうのは
いろいろ専任決める時でも
初めはもう反対 邪教だ
外道だとか言いながら
それでもうどうも抑えられないんですね
いいことをする人はね
決して誰にも抑えることはできないんです
それで悔しくてしょうがないんだから認めてあげる
で マザーテレサの場合も同じで
ものあまりにもインドの世界で行動しているんだから無視できないんだから
どんどん認めるようになったら
その方があなたに何か必要なものがあるんだったら言ってくださいと言ったら
もう何か私に車一台欲しいんだという
それでロールスロイスですか？ロールスロイス車一台貰ったんだと
ローマ法王もすごく威張って欲しかったかもしれません
マザーテレサさんがロールスロイスに乗ってインドあっちこっち行ったりして
この社会福祉が行動するんだと
そんなことやっちゃったらもうひどい目にあいますからね
もうあんたそのためにやっただろうと
でも彼女はそのためにやったわけじゃないんです
あの味を味わうためにやったことなんです
ですから 私は社会福祉活動をしているんだと言って
偉そうにロールスロイス車に乗っていく気は全くなくて
この車をもらったからすぐ売った
あれ売って金儲かりたくて頼んだんですね
そこで車ものすごい高い高値で売れたそうで
そのお金を持ってきて
また自分の福祉活動に使ったんです
ですから 客観的に見れば
あの女何やってるんですかとと思うかもしれません
そんなことを構わず 自分がこの福祉する
奉仕をする その喜びを味わいたい
それは充実感であり それは幸福である
その心はいつでも喜びを感じて生きていられる
せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
喜び感じるのはなぜ悪いかと
生命というのは幸福を目指しているんだから
それはもう遠い遠い未来でなんで幸福を目指すというのはもうおかしいし
ですから今幸福を味わえない人は
もう明日も幸福を味わえないんですよ
今幸福を味わう方法を知っている人は
明日今になったところで
じゃあ今日はどうすればいいかということはすぐわかるし
ですから 遠い将来幸福になりますと思う人々は
もう明日幸福になりますよということだから
永遠に幸福にはならないんです
今日今私は幸せですよという充実感ないと
ですから 心は幸福を目指目指しているんだから
すぐ幸福 喜び 充実感を味わわなくちゃいけない
それ一旦味わったら その方法で先があるならば
行動はどうであろうと
ずっと幸福感を味わって生きることはできるんです
そういう人々 体が病気になったんだからとか
体と関係なく 心の喜びを味わって生きていられることはできるんですね
ですから この そういう世界の仏教からの科学的な合理的な分析ですね
今説明してます で 宗教に入ると
宗教のこの概念で解釈するんだから
もう神話的なんです あるいはマザー・テレサが初めて出会ったあの女の人は
神様のメッセンジャーであったとか
あるいはそれをその人こそ神様でしたと
何でも言えますよ そうすると
それをその人の文化の解釈であって
神話的な解釈であって
科学的な説明にはならないんです
なぜならば なんでマザー・テレサだけに神様が出会って
そういう善行を作る条件を作ってあげたんですかと
他の人になんで作ってあげないんですかと
とちょっと文句言いたくなるんですね
みんないいことをして喜びを味わいたいんだから
みんなに平等に機会を与えなさいとは言いたくなる
そうすると宗教家がみんなに与えてるんだと言うかもしれません
みんな気づいてないんだと
で なんで我々にも気づくようにしてくれないかと
また我々に文句言うんですよ
だから宗教の定義入ってくるともう無茶苦茶なんです
あまり大したことはない
そうじゃなくて やっぱり合理的に解釈した方が誰にでも実行できますよ
だからこういう解釈であるならば
これは宗教と関係なく
人類誰にでも実行できます
だから まあ基本的にはこの明るい心
充実感感じる心が善の心
いわゆる生命が本当に探し求めているのはそういう心なんです
でも 例えば愛情が欲しい子供が母親をぶん殴ると
無茶苦茶でしょうね ぶん殴ったら愛情のところじゃなくて
もうカウンセラーのところに引っ張られちゃうし
どうかの少年院とか何とかいうところあるみたいですね
そういうところに出しちゃうし
せっかく自分が欲しがってる愛情はなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことをみんなやってるんです
我々 ちょっと精神的な異常の子供たちみたいに
この子供たちがかわいそうだと
もう愛情が欲しくて もうとんでもないことやってるから
人のこと言うんだけど
人類っていうのはみんな幸福が欲しくて無茶な方向に行って
せっかくの幸福を失ってしまう
不幸を味わう それはまあ
そこはなんとかやめて
どうやって不幸を味わう
幸福が欲しくて貪瞋痴の行動をする
怒りむさぼりの行動をする
嫉妬したり 戦ったり ライバルを作ったり
自我を作ったり 高慢を作ったりして
自分と他人の区別をして
自分がいると他人もいるんだから
自分一人になっちゃうんです
それで世界的に回して行動しなくちゃいけない
世界的に回すと これで勝つということは絶対ありえないんだから
最低な幸福 不幸になってしまうんです
そこで自我を捨てなさいと
嫉妬するのをやめなさいと
慈しみの心を作リなさいというのは
自分という実体的な概念を捨てることによって
そうすると自分消えたところで他人もない
他人もないところでライバルはいない
スムーズに空気のように生きていられるし
そうすると最高な幸福をその人々は味わうのです
だから生命っていうのは
幸福というものは生きがいにして
それを探し求めている
なかなか見つからない
で それだったら これ大したことではないんだと
鼻の先にあるんだと 今すぐ幸福になるんだと
ということは仏教で教えているところなんです
他の宗教でもまあ同じく幸福はこうに
こうなりますよということは言ってますけど
で まあ合理的とか普遍性から見ると
仏教の方がものすごく合理的で普遍性があって実践的なんですね
実践すればすぐできるというぐらいの差なんです
じゃあ まあ大体人間に一番必要なのはこの善心性だから
我々育てるべきは善心性だから
不善心性は勉強するべきであって
それを育てる必要はないんです
ですから まあ延々と私は時間をかけて喋りましたけど
その十九は確実にあるもので
十九種類のもの だからいつでも明るくいる生活することを覚悟しなくちゃいけない
たとえ病気になって倒れても
心だけは明るくと 痛い痛いって文句言うんじゃなくてね
例えば病気になったら
もうあっちこっち痛くてしょうがない
みんなもう文句言うわ
医者に文句言うわ みんなに文句言うわ
自分に文句言うわ もう親に文句言うわ
そういうのはもう生き地獄なんですね
生きている 生きながらも地獄の味
たとえ体病気になっても
文句言わないで明るく
明るく 明るく 楽しく生きていればいいんです
どんな病気になろうとも
それは関係ないんです
お金が入ろうとも 入らなくても
お金がなくなっても ものすごく明るくいれば
もう何が悪いかと だから人間ってバカバカな人
お金がなくなったと そうするとすぐ落ち込んじゃうんですね
なんで落ち込むんですかね
お金がなくなっても 別に明るくいたっても大したことないのに
ですから 例えば旦那さんが逃げてしまったと
別にいいんじゃないんですか
逃げたって だからといって
私は不幸だ なんで私のような不幸な人間いるんですかとか
なんで私に限ってそんなものになるんですかとか
それ全部不幸な怒りの思考なんですね
その時言えるのは あなたはそういう人間だから逃げたんですよと
これからもあなたには誰も寄ってこないんだと
ですから 旦那さんが逃げたって
自分がまあすごく明るくて元気で
自分の日常の行動は何のことなくすると
お金がなくなっても 別に悩んだり悔しがったりすると
もう全部損だけなんですね
で 明るく行動すると 決して不幸にはならない
みんな問題だと思うものは一つもなくなって消えてしまうんです
将来について不安というとすごい不安でしょうに
そういう人々は今も不安で不幸で生活しているんです
だから 何があろうとも
心の明るさだけはもう絶対守りましょうと
という覚悟で生きている人はもうずっと幸福になる
だから悟らない限りは
この幸福にはいつでも攻撃します
攻撃されます 例えばすごい元気だ
今日はどこかへ出かけましょうと言ったところで行って
楽しく遊びましょうと言ったところで
大雨が降るかもしれません
そうすると ああ 嫌だ この雨はとかね
文句言いたくなるんですね
ですから せっかくの楽しみがちょっとした原因で消えるんです
だから気をつけなくちゃいけない
心にはいつでも怒りが生まれる可能性あります
それはどこかでライブに行ったんだと
そこでちょっと車どこかで泊まろうとしたところで
なんとかしてタイヤがパンクしましたと
ああ やれやれと ああ 嫌だと
やっぱり今日はもう出かけるべきではなかったとか
悔しがったりする 今日はもう何占いで方向を占うでしょうに
出かける前に方位学で言われるものなんてもらった方がいいんではないかとかね
という風ないろんなことをしたりして
とにかく悔しがったり悩んだりする
そういう性格が我々にはあります
ですから たとえ明るくしようと思っても
瞬間瞬間我々に現れる現象というのは無常なものだから
何が起こるか分かったもんじゃ
知ったもんではないんです
ですから ずっと気づくことをすると
何があろうとももう心は暗くしないようと
という覚悟が必要なんです
不幸が出てくると不幸に笑うと
例えばある人々いますよ
何か病気があると それなんとかやっとそれ治してもらったところで
他のところでまた違う病気が出て
それなんとか頑張って頑張って治すところで
まだ他の何か出てくる
そういう人々はいるんですけど
だからってその人はなぜ不幸にならなくちゃいけないんですか？生まれてから死ぬまで何とか病気
病で病んでるんだ 悩んでるんだと
だから だからといってなぜ不幸ですかね
不幸になる必要はないんです
ですから もう一つの何か病気にかかったところで
それを治療しながら まあこれこの治療でこれ治りますけど
次にどんな病気になるかは分からないんだとかね
それは明るく見ておけばそれだけのこと
肺がやられると それ何とかして
もう肺 次に腎臓にいったんだ
腎臓 じゃあ腎臓を修理しようと
それやったら次になんとか他のところに行ったと
それは高血圧になりました
それお薬飲んでるとまた神経もどんどん弱くなったとか
そういう風に次から次へと病気が出てくる人もいるし
全然病気にならない人もいるし
ですから すごく常に明るい心で
そんなものに笑って 自分自身のことにもなんか笑ってごまかして
ごまかすのではなくてね
そういうのに笑ってからかってるような状態で生活しなくちゃいけない
その明るさなんですね
精神というのは 山口の説法で言ったのは
この たとえ自分の家が火事になっても笑顔を忘れるなと
バカバカしい 家が火事になったんだから泣くのは
何で泣くんですか？泣くと家
泣くと火事になった火が消えるならば
もう私も泣いてあげますけど
もし泣いたところで もう家が全部燃えちゃって
それからざーっと新しい家ができてくるならば
もうみんな一緒にいて泣いてあげますよ
私だけじゃ いろんな人で
じゃあ行って泣いてあげましょうと
どうでも燃えるものは燃えるんだから
そんなものはどうでもいいやと
自分の笑顔だけ 心の落ち着きだけはもう壊さないように常に気をつけなくちゃいけない
そこ大変だから お釈迦様がもう絶対的に最終的にこの怒りやら貪瞋痴を心から捨てろと
もう二度と生まれないようにしてしまえと
そうすると気づく必要なくなっちゃうんです
別に それで幸福というものが確立するんだと
だから幸福になることはいつでもできますけど
ちょっとしたことでそれ壊れちゃうんですね
我々作る幸福っていうのは
ですから そこがもう心の弱みですから
いくら気が強く持っていても
やっぱり次から次へと不幸なことに出会うと
もうお手上げ状態になる可能性はいつでもありますから
それだったら まあ最終的に心のこの汚す
心が心を汚す原因を全部もう取り払ってください
それだったらもう心配することなく
自分を守る必要もなくなっちゃう
気をつける必要もなくなっちゃう
だから修行をし終えたと
なすべきことを成し終えたという状態をお釈迦様は言ってるんで
やることないんだと やることないんだっていうのは
この暗い考え方ではなくて
もう終わったよというゴールだよとということなんで
言っているのは で  そういうことで
次の説明に行きましょう
次にこのヴィラティチェータシカという 3つあるんです
51ページ サンマーワーチャ
サンマーカンマントゥ
サンマーアジーヴォ サンマーワーチャは正語
また正語 で サンマーアジーヴォ
アジーヴォっていうのは正命
で その 3つはこの八正道にも出てくるんです
で 全部心所として八正道の 3つしか使ってないんです
他の 5つはちゃんと心所としてあるんです
リストの中に ですから
あの 言葉違うだけで 例えば正念
単なる念として入ってるし
で 八正道の 1番目はサンマーディッティ
正見 それは あの 後から出てきます
で 他に入ってます で 正精進があります
サンマーヴァーヤ それはウィリヤとして
精進として 精進として
あの どこかに入ってるはずなんです
どこかわからないんだけど
とにかく全部入ってるんです
だから入ってないのはこのヴィラティという何か悪いことをしないという 3つなんです
正語 正業と正言と正命
それはもうわかりやすいのはこの戒律の世界
律の世界なんですね 戒めの世界
で 自分をコントロールする
いくらかは 悪い意味のコントロールじゃなくて
このコントロールしなきゃ危ないんだ
例えば車を運転するってことは
別にコントロールしなくてもいいんだという人がいませんから
上手な運転手っていうのは
徹底的に車をコントロールする人なんですよ
だからコントロールという言葉はすぐ暗く感じるんだけど
自由を奪うという意味じゃなくて
うまく操縦するという意味なんです
人生を だから人生の操縦すること
戒律であって律なんです
何か抑えること 抑圧することではないんです
そこをすごく あの 理解しておかなくちゃいけない
だからこの戒律で仏教で追いしがっている
我々に言っているのは
もう自分の人生というもののものについては
立派な操縦士になってくださいということなんです
ちゃんと操縦しなさいと
そうするともう別に問題ないんだ
操縦できない人はもう何もこの人生という
その大変複雑な この 複雑な
何て言いますか これ行動できているもの
システムだから この複雑な組織をうまく使えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから 命というものの上手な操縦の仕方
戒律であります そこはもう簡単に心所として見ると 3つしか
心所として見ると 操縦すると我々には何て言いますか
スイッチ 3つしかないんですよ
たくさんこの飛行機のコックピットみたいに
もうみるみるとこれいろんな計器があって
いろんなスイッチがあって
もう見ただけでももう嫌になるほどでしょうに
それあまりにもありすぎたから
飛行機でも今操縦は一番しやすいんです
一つ二つ  3つしかないんですよ
このパイロットが操縦するものは
他のものは全部自動 全部自動
一旦離陸したらみんなそのままスイッチ入れてもう立って
あっち行ったりこっち行ったり
ご飯食べたり お客さんと喋ったりとか
お客様は気が付かないかもしれませんけども
もう誰もいないんです
一番飛行機の前に乗ったら
乗っていたら見えますよ
ドアも離陸する時は鍵かけてますけど
それから開けてしまいますからね
それでもう人がもう立っていく
あちこちと人で喋ってる
それで話に乗ってしまえば
もう10分  15分でも喋るんです
で その間全部自動操縦でもう行ってしまう
それはそれで とにかく複雑なスイッチいっぱいあっても
それはコントロールできないんだから
単純化して まあコンピューターでもいろいろそこでコンピューターからちゃんと